that's kind of the first step and many
of many of those people who I see are
joining The Barking movement or really
like neurotic about performance in many
ways do you think that is a good thing
or a bad thing I see many of them being
quite unhealthy with it and what it
enables them to do is the same but in an
accelerated manner so suddenly they
start popping nootropics
it's a big big thing you know that you
can have increased mental performance
even physical performance maybe some
athletes also look for I mean but
they've been doing supplements for 20-30
years already pretty consistently so
that's nothing new but when it comes to
working in front of your computer
suddenly there's more than coffee that
you can take to stay awake and focus
that your work so to me they are seeking
a solution to their problem and once
they get some advantage from this they
push the envelope even further and I
don't think that's very healthy so I see
a lot of bikers like not really pushing
away their old lifestyles so they must
be still sleeping quite little but
they're doing all these nootropics and
diets that keeps the inflammation lower
so they can get more out of the system
I'm joined by Teemu arena author of the
biohackers handbook an all-round
fascinating guy welcome to the show
wonderful to be here I am getting big
podcast studio envy of the lovely setup
that you have in front of you yeah I
mean I do a lot of things nowadays
online and it was only like a couple of
weeks ago I was presenting to a huge
Russian IT technology conference and I
don't like travel nowadays that much
because I've been doing 100 talks a year
for the last five six years so I just
like to hang around in my studio and I
figured out that you know this is the
best way to do it so I can do live
streams anywhere and in create audio
great video so I loved it doing this way
and it also helps me to keep my daily
routines with design as a biohacker you
want to maximize your productivity and
recovery and all that if you fly into a
conference for what giving a 30 minute
or 1 hour talk and you spend time in
airplanes and in public transport and
eating all kinds of crappy whatever you
know Airport or conference food I think
it's more efficient to just stay here I
might not you know make those
face-to-face connections but if I met
the people before that's the way I
prefer to do it yeah there's an
interesting so two camps of people as
far as I can see there's people who
understand that trying to focus on
efficiency and marginal gains in the way
that you've eluded to that is something
which is kind of what everything else
emerges from and if you look after those
small things that everything else comes
along as a byproduct and then there the
there are the people who see that as a
bipartite it's like no no I've got to
get on the plane because I got to go to
the thing and that's the way it's gonna
be done you got it you got it it's
basically one of the principles of
biohacking
is the daily decrease how do you
decrease the amount of
useless things that you shouldn't be
doing and basically looking for what is
the 20% that will give you the 80
personal results an output that was
Italian mathematician mr. Perret who
actually first devised and outlined the
fact that in many things in economy
nature workplaces everywhere is based on
the 20/80 principle so for example 20%
of people produce 80 percent of results
if you take any kind of ant nest
actually we think that ants are
extremely hardworking you know guys and
girls all of them but actually most of
them are slaking they did say that
through yeah they did some studies on
ant nest and they realized that 80% of
them are actually slacking around and
not really doing much so there is a
small number who is always doing the
work so what I'm saying is that you know
you know it's up to you if you want to
be focusing your time or the 80% that
will result in only 20% of the results
or if you want to seek for the 20% that
will result in 80% of improvement so
with that I mean you can't optimize
everything you can't really predict
everything I leave a lot also in my life
to serendipity serendipity in science as
being key for many discoveries so people
who are seeking for something people who
are seeking for something completely
different
stumbled upon a totally different
invention so for example post-it notes
the guys who are trying to work on the
most efficient glue and they actually
made the worst possible glue and it
required a little bit of inventiveness
to be able to realize that hey this can
be used for something else and that also
applies to relationships and that
applies to many things in nature if you
want to discover things there is
probably a lot of things that you will
discover by just exposing yourself to
different environments so that's another
part of biohacking is that it's not
really about optimizing yourself
it is about optimizing your relationship
to your environment and
the more I look at it and the more I
look at the different trends in
biohacking
which we can also dive into because I'm
also the creator of biacore Summit I've
been doing that for the last five years
we donate events in different countries
and what I've noticed is a shift more
and more towards optimizing your
environment your light environment your
water your you know it could be even
your own microbiome which is actually
outside of you you're kind of like a
hollow tube and there's all these
bacteria that live in your digestive
tract and on your skin everywhere and
you live in a symbiotic relationship
with all those guys and you can't be
separate from them if you want to have
good health and that also applies to so
many other things like our connection to
nature that our food chain and all of
that so when I look at my home or my
office I'm always always kind of
thinking about the ways how I can prime
my environment so that it gives me the
best possible conditions for optimal
performance in health and well-being and
and not always it's about Calvinistic
utility driven needs I think that that's
a misconception in a lot of kind of
high-performance and self development
talk is the need to somehow be in grip
of what you're doing and if you look at
quantified self measuring yourself
tracking yourself with an aura like
trying to get you know perfect night's
sleep
that's the utility value but part of it
is also self realization and self
expression so the data itself enables
you to express yourself and it also
helps you to reflect back on you who you
are in what place here in the universe
and what you're up to and it brings up
important questions like if you start
tracking your sleep you start to ask
questions like why do you sleep how do
you sleep how long do you sleep and the
fact of measuring itself already
the equation so when you start tracking
your steps or your sleep you're already
changing your sleep and your mobility
and movement so to me it is also about
understanding that what you pay
attention to what you focus on is in
terms of your own behaviors you're
already part of that equation so you're
already taking the first steps by using
some may be external ways or keys or
cues to tap into your own behavior so if
you do journaling for example that's a
big thing also in biocking is like doing
you know maybe daily affirmations or
having some kind of gratitude gratitude
journal down good it's late so yeah so
all of those are priming you for the day
and helping it attention to the signals
are key in your environment it can be to
two different people exactly the same
conditions and the environments the
other one is freaking out and the other
one is enjoying him or herself there is
a saying that when it rains
some people get wet and some people feel
the rain on their skin so it's a matter
of perspective and what these things are
really helping you it is to gain a
perspective to yourself and that to me
what that that is what biocking is to me
this much it is a modern approach to
enlightenment in a way it is using
modern tools combined with ancient
wisdom and natural living principles
systems from I mean there's so many
biocking systems that have existed for
thousands of years you take yoga
meditation you know different schools of
martial art different nutritional
schools from you know from Mediterranean
diets to to let's say a very very much
of wild her plant-based stuff that we do
here in the North in Finland it is you
know we are standing on the shoulders of
giants there's so many people have
mapped
the territory and they've mapped really
like what is key to understanding your
place in this universe and this human
being and also to kind of push your
boundaries so if you think of like a
martial artist like you take any of
these Eastern schools I practiced myself
some Aikido for example and the Japanese
the Chinese ours also some some goon foo
Tai Chi I've done also and what I
learned from those is that as much as
you focus on the ability to produce
extreme force with the least amount of
effort you also practice the counter of
that which is meditation and breathing
techniques and all that so that's also
what biocking should be it's not about
better faster stronger
it is also wiser it is also about more
being reflective on how you do things
and not always try to you know sleep
four hours a night and you know a fourth
coffee and yeah I think certainly a lot
of people that are listening may think
that when you hear the word biohacking
for most people who are maybe uneducated
about it I think a lot of terms come to
mind about people being quite
utilitarian quite transactional with
these marginal gains and things like
that I recently had a discussion with
Stephen Wolfram now he as the listeners
will know if you've been tuning in and
if you haven't you need to go back and
check it out it's an awesome episode
the he's tracked I think three million
emails that he sent over the last thirty
years and about thirty million
keystrokes used them through pioneer of
self tracking
yeah it's it's to a degree of fidelity
that at least with regards to work that
I've never I've never really seen before
but what he actually had is his
justification for it was quite
philosophical and pretty beautiful that
he said I like to work I like my job and
I like what I do at work
why would I not facilitate me doing as
much of what I like to do as efficiently
and as effectively as I can and I think
that transcends for me what before you
know so we've got by hackers handbook
here in front of me
it's a beastly a beastly thing there are
also is that as a reference just in case
you forget some of the things that we
need to go back to you know before you
have a look through that and I guess
with one reading you could potentially
see each of them as discrete individual
hacks or techniques or whatever it is
but the emergent end result of this is
that you're able to do more of the
things you want to do you can spend more
time in good health we I recently spoke
to Professor David Sinclair from Harvard
Medical School and he was talking about
just making people live longer and he
talks about the health span not just the
lifespan it's like feeling better for
longer having more energy to do the
things that you care about etc etc so I
think you've given us a pretty robust
introduction to bio hacking there so far
where would you say are the key areas
that buy a hack is tend to focus on so
what you actually described already like
what kind of people are drawn to bio
hacking the kind of utilitarian got
people those people are often struggling
already with our modern society like
they try to push themselves for results
so those might be startup entrepreneurs
they might be I don't know some high
street investors or real estate brokers
or you name it like people who are
really you know working insane hours and
not really taking any vacation so they
struggle with hormonal imbalances they
struggle with all kinds of blood sugar
regulation issues they might suffer from
gut dysbiosis there is so many things
that they
seek an answer for in in biohacking
and they might try things like ketogenic
diet and see that the lights go on
suddenly and they might start tracking
their sleep and trying to figure out
like how to get more deep sleep with the
amount of sleep that they're getting and
to me
that's kind of the first step and many
of many of those people who I see are
joining the barking movement or really
like neurotic about performance in many
ways do you think that is a good thing
or is a bad thing I see many of them
being quite unhealthy with it and what
it enables them to do is the same but in
an accelerated manner so suddenly they
start popping nootropics
it's a big big thing you know that you
can have increased mental performance
even physical performance maybe some
athletes also look for I mean but
they've been doing supplements for 20-30
years already pretty consistently so
that's nothing new but when it comes to
working in front of your computer
suddenly there's more than coffee that
you can take to stay awake and focus
that your work so to me they are seeking
a solution to their problem and once
they get some advantage from this they
push the envelope even further and I
don't think that's very healthy so I see
a lot of bikers like not really pushing
away their old lifestyles so they must
be still sleeping quite little but
they're doing all these nootropics and
diets that keeps the inflammation lower
so they can get more out of the system
so they're basically choosing themselves
faster and once they take all the
nootropics that you take something like
modafinil already take you know adderall
or or you take some you know stack of
supplements often there is side effects
that are related to increased heart rate
so once you increase
blood flow once you expand capillaries
yeah you improve nutrient flow but once
you get like five ten beats higher heart
rate because of doing all of that
I wouldn't be surprised if down the road
you age faster for me so many different
reasons and it's if you think of the
heart as a muscle it's a mechanical
muscle that is doing work when it when
the heart rate goes up the time speeds
up when the heart rate goes down the
time slows down so that's why it's so
super important to do things to counter
that kind of behavior which is
meditation breathing techniques just
going for a nature walk whatever and if
you're only doing all the nootropics
and you're doing all that you know you
can you can do many of these things in
excess even things like red light
therapy for mitochondrial function or
things like antioxidants there is a
dose-response curve too many things also
nootropics so basically those response
curve describes the fact that there is a
sweet spot for dosage if you if you get
too much you get side effects you get
potentially dangerous imbalance is also
if you do too little that's also I mean
that's often what people are correcting
but then they go to the extreme they
might be using blue light blocking
glasses all day long so that's the thing
there they might be drinking bulletproof
coffee all day long there is a balance
the things and I think there is a need
for homeostasis in biohacking
so most Oz is in medical terms is the is
that is the balance that your body
strives for and if you are artificially
tilting it to a certain direction like
constantly pumping up your heart rate
and blood flow I don't think that's
healthy so I mean I come from Europe
we we are slightly different than
Americans for example I feel that the
American culture of biohacking is much
more like performance driven while the
Europeans like I mean in the north in
Finland which is by the way one of the
barking capitals of Europe if you look
go to any of these health food shops we
have we have we have great products and
companies and huge eyes awesome you can
get in every supermarket there is super
food sections you can buy MCT oil from
all the large super supermarkets like
it's and it's all high-quality also you
get really high quality coffee yeah so
it's all available but people are driven
more by things that come from wild
nature like extracts from medicinal
mushrooms like chaga they might be
getting bilberry extracts which is
basically the more pronounced
exponentially more powerful the original
form of a blueberry the blueberry that
is sold as a superfood is actually the
one that grows in a bush is quite high
on sugar and it's not I mean so it's a
wussy compared to a bilberry with which
is basically growing on the ground
you still bury it bilberries a hardcore
blueberry yeah yeah if you if you cut a
blueberry you can see that the things
that give blueberries the color the
anthocyanins which are also the
dimensions or properties of blueberries
that are being thrown around
we are also great for eye health and all
that
extremely strong antioxidants often
these very dark pigments are like that
you take coffee chocolate chaga mushroom
's you take blueberries the the dark
pigments are usually very strong
antioxidants now in blueberries you have
only these pigments in the skin section
a little bit maybe one or two
millimeters below the skin but if you
take a bilberry
that's the original bad ass [ __ ]
version of the blueberry the blueberries
selectively bred kind of saying that you
know it's bigger and as more suger
content but if you take a bill berry you
cut it it's it's all throughout these
dark pigments and it has so much more
flavor the same goes for raspberries the
local raspberries we have here those are
much more but they pack all the bitter
compounds all the nutrient dense stuff
in there so anyway so in Finland it's
not really that much about supplements
it's really about the real foods I get
you and that's the thing I don't know if
it's part of the culture that we have
every man's rights that you can actually
go to nature on private land and you can
pick anything you want and you're not
being chased chased down it's okay it's
part of the Nordic culture here in
Sweden and Finland and Estonia you can
go to the nature you can take berries
mushrooms herbs from someone's backyard
and it's okay I think you would you
probably be chased out of someone's
backyard in the UK if you try to do that
here exactly so at the same in u.s. so
people are not really accustomed to the
fact that nature is theirs but here it's
I mean we have 100 thousand lakes sauna
the Finnish sauna is part of our culture
it has always been it was the method
through which we heated our homes did
that we did everything where sometimes
people leave that Sun is on or out
overnight and sometimes neighbors just
go and use other people's soreness
yeah public sauna culture is is big but
you're probably referring to the smoke
sauna smoke zone as something which you
heat with smoke in the end you don't
have smoke in there but you basically
use that to really bring the temperature
up and then you do all the heat this is
is in a huge pile of stones and it keeps
hot for 48 hours
it also takes at least six hours often
12 hours to heat a proper finish smoke
sauna and and the great you know a
proper smoke zone also burns at least
once in ten years to the ground and you
build it again you can't have those in
apartment building so what we have Nala
days in apartment buildings are this I
guess they are like electric grills so
electric sauna it's not a you drilling
yourself yeah really yeah but the
problem with these electric stoves
is that they reduce the humidity in the
air yeah and often because they are in
apartment buildings you don't have
direct connection to air and the
greatest qualities of a proper sauna
experience are actually invisible
they're not physical so it's it is the
combination of the basic elements of
water fire air and then you have earth
which is basically the stones and you
throw water on the stones and the water
evaporates and that is called load which
is the spirit of the sauna and in some
countries here in the Baltics for
example in lot beyond and Slovakia they
they hang this different herbs in the
ceiling and once the water evaporates it
takes the volatile oils with them and
carries them in the air to your lungs so
that's the essential oils thing yeah now
we don't need a diffuser for it you just
go for a sauna and then you also make
this I don't know how you call them but
you basically put a bunch of branches
together usually birch some other
countries here in politics they also use
other trees like maybe oak leaves or
maple whatever you know you can just
make one of these from just about
anything tie it up and heat yourself
with it and it really brings the blood
flow on the surface and you also
basically literally beat the volatile
oils into your skin
now now that's good actually in Finland
they also used stinging nettle that is
hardcore yeah you basically get a bunch
of stinging nettle together and you beat
someone you know who it that is a friend
you beat a friend or you be an enemy you
beat you beat a friend who has kidney
problems in the back' and it increases
blood flow greatly I mean you probably
got sting by stinging nettle at some
point and it's agony and it's it really
increased blood flow that's medicine man
might hurt for a while but it's good for
you
definitely hurt for a while so yeah you
can also I mean Sian it's one of the
highest sources of micronutrients that
you can get from your backyard Wow I
mean if anyone who is listening at home
I implore you not to blame on us if you
eat a stinging nettle and it hurts I'm
going to advise you to almost almost
definitely will hurt but yes so you've
touched on a number of areas there that
I think a lot of people will consider
they'll think about the fact that they
need to focus on the sleep I need to
track my sleep I need to understand that
it's not just getting eight hours it's
getting varieties of REM sleep etc etc
you've done so on the therapy as well
and a few different creation yeah we
combined gas also I swimming so we
basically combine that I can get into
the details of the health effects if
you're interested but that'd be good
that's about but anyway so in this book
we we go through five pillars of your
life sleep exercise nutrition mind and
work and how you can see all of those
systems and how you can track them and
how it can optimize them based on latest
science so heath alteration is something
that you can use to improve your
recovery from things like exercise or it
can be a form of exercise actually if
you go if you don't exercise at all but
you go for a sauna once a week it it is
already a really good training for your
cardiovascular system
and you reduce your risk of
cardiovascular disease by that already
and you also improve your immunity
it increases white blood cell count and
certain immune system cells also
something called heat shock proteins
proliferate when you expose yourself to
hot and cold by the way also actually
heat shock proteins on a cellular level
were discovered when they studied cells
in the real and they they realized that
certain proteins increase in the number
once you exposed the cells to heat
that's why they call them heat shock
proteins but then they realized later on
that it also is something that increased
number when you expose the cell to cold
or radiation a bunch of different
environmental stressors and it seems
that it's key for its recovery or self
repair mechanisms so it will clean out
inter-cell or waste and it will also
activate certain pathways that are
related to longevity black fox o3 so so
there are many benefits of that what has
not been studied well it very well is
the combination of sauna and I swimming
combined those are being studied in
isolation so called exposure and heat
exposure if someone is interested in
like okay if I go for a traditional
Finnish sauna or a dry sauna how do I
get the health benefits now what is the
protocol what you should aim for is that
you wait until your heart rate goes up
that's when you are generating those
heat shock proteins and you're you're
getting many of the benefits to your
cardiovascular system and when you go
for I swimming a good duration is once
once you get in there and you start
hyperventilating you stay there until
your breathing gets even you just try to
kind of read through it and that's once
you get past a certain point you are
already you have already you know got
the shock to your
nervous system that is beneficial in
this context and also the cardiovascular
benefits so another thing that for
ladies out there is key is also skin now
your skin is your largest organ and most
of the time we spend our time in pretty
much heated environments in a tropical
environment almost like heated indoors
cars we have all kinds of air
conditioning and heating systems in
buildings now we don't really expose
ourselves nowadays that much to heat
alteration now if you do that on a
regular basis it will also improve your
skin quality for many many many reasons
part of it is related to the expansion
and contraction of capillaries of micro
veins and there's many benefits to that
so yeah I think some of the best bio
hacks are actually pretty simple and not
very straightforward stuff right I mean
how often are you suggesting or what
what appears to be optimal twice a week
three times a week I would recommend
doing it two or three times a week but
if you even do it once a week you reduce
your risk for seasonal flu by 66% insane
statistic yeah so I don't need much okay
so we've got we've we've got sauna heat
and cold therapy is one of the one of
the top lists oh okay if we were to take
that if you were to I'm aware that with
biohacking bio markers are a key element
of what we're talking about here that
it's not simply a one-size-fits-all
solution and that people need to make
adjustments to their own home yet to
reach homeostasis and to then improve on
that based on where their imbalances lie
and yours will not be the same as mine
will not be the same as the listeners at
home yeah if if I was to ask you for
your as the experience that you've seen
and with the broad cross-section of the
public which you've been exposed to what
would you say
the rough-hewn what's the 80/20 of the
80/20 for people to look at doing if it
was to be a top five things that most
people could benefit from are your
favorite things that most people could
benefit from that you think of emerged
from the biohacking community recently
yeah if you look at biomarkers what you
should pay attention to so so I'm not a
big fan of any kind of reductionist
logic that you break down a human being
to a single number well actually your
blood sugar Valley or something like
this but in the end those are pretty
good indicators and many of them but a
combination of them is perhaps even more
beneficial so what I would look for is
it's certainly that classical ones I
would look at your fasting blood glucose
but not just your glucose tolerance test
but your long-term hemic lobbying a1c is
is I think one of the key markers to
follow on so that you understand your
long-term exposure to blood sugar
fluctuations the other one that I would
look for is definitely lipid biomarkers
that is really the cholesterol but I
wouldn't look at total cholesterol I
would look at three Saucer IDEs and
their relationship to HDL LDL
cholesterol and and that is already
giving pretty good indicators of of
where you are in terms of particle size
versus cholesterol levels and
cholesterol is a carrier
so when inflammation goes up cholesterol
levels tend to also rise when you
exercise a lot your cholesterol tends to
rise so it doesn't only rise when you
eat food that is high in cholesterol
it arises in response to your your
day-to-day activities and now what is
kind of key to understand there is
definitely information so high
cholesterol it's not that dangerous if
you have low information of high
inflammation then there's a risk that
you down into your arterial walls and
that creates problems then with high
cholesterol so now what you
tract for is things like homocysteine
and high highly-sensitive c-reactive
protein they often check for CRP but
that tells you more about things like
bacterial infection or a massive
systemic infection or inflammation going
on but if you track your highly
sensitive c-reactive protein you get a
better idea of low level inflammation
which kills you over time and kind of
exposes you to to all these degenerative
disease that come with age even things
like Alzheimer's and and cardiovascular
disease that works in slowly or or
inability to deal with glucose or
insulin resistance now what I would look
for definitely in terms of sleep quality
is the amount of deep sleep I wouldn't
look at sleep duration I would look at
dumb out of deep sleep because deep
sleep is the key face when you're at
sleep in the first stages of sleep when
you get most of your deep sleep usually
that's when your brain shrinks a little
bit and there are this the lymphatic
system expands to the brain and it's
mediated by glial cells in the brain and
it pumps out any of the metabolic
byproducts that accumulate throughout
the day so basically being awake is a
catabolic state it breaks your body down
now when you sleep that's an anabolic
state when you build up things and you
clean out things and do dfrac yourself
and that's where things like amyloid
Blake or amyloid beta which accumulates
in Alzheimer's disease tend to be
cleaned out now if you don't get proper
deep sleep which comes in the first four
or five hours of the night you're not
cleaning that's just improperly and one
easy way to reduce the amount of deep
sleep is actually to drink more than two
glasses of alcohol so obviously I mean
many of these things that we already
know why excess consumption of alcohol
or smoking see
is definitely linked to many of these
conditions one of one of my friends
recently I was having a discussion with
him and I was we are big advocates of
going sober on this show I've currently
just testing myself to see if I can do
18 months sober
I run club nights which means that it's
the exact opposite of what everyone else
is doing but it's a good it's a good
challenge and I am enjoying at the
moment yeah I actually I actually met a
DJ friend today who's into electronic
music and he also said like I mean he's
into biohacking nowadays but he spent
most of his youth basically like you
know what ah da got ya and watching when
other people like get wasted and it I
mean I was just like a couple of nights
ago I was or yesterday maybe two two
yeah yesterday I was in the evening I
was in a just a summer you know first
outdoor event here and I just realized
that um I mean how many people are
smoking cigarettes still I don't get
this passive smoking thing at all
nowadays but when you go to a place like
that I realized that hmm okay some
people are still doing this blows my
mind man like it's there's been the anti
smoking or the I guess the smoking
health advertisements especially in the
UK have done such a good job I'm
terrified of being near a cigarette now
and I kind of always have been the fact
that people still see it as a viable
thing to do to me kind of kind of blows
my mind but yeah so speaking of my
friend and I was he was talking to me
about how he said alcohol helps me sleep
better at night and I was like you're
not sleeping you're sedating yourself
and there's a big difference between the
two and going to bed sedated is not it's
got nothing to do with sleep it's just
the fact that you've knocked yourself
out with two too big glasses of red wine
like that yeah yeah drinking wine in the
evening on it that increases GABA
neurotransmitters in the brain with an
inhibitory neurotransmitter so it slows
down signaling so definitely it relaxes
you and you feel like you're more easily
to go to sleep but it can also inhibit
your deep sleep stages and
and depending of your genetic makeup so
one thing one kind of key thing to look
for if you do any of these genetic tests
is to look for your cytochrome p450
system in your liver how it basically
metabolize things like alcohol or
caffeine so if you are fast or slow
metabolize if your if your liver is able
to produce you two months of glutathione
that breaks down alcohol yeah I mean
you're you're gonna say first side if
you get a red flash reaction from
alcohol you should stop immediately yeah
my business my business partner Dave is
Asian heritage and he still gets asian
beer flush which he has to take his
little tablets for and stuff for anyone
who is this thing that doesn't know what
this is you may have an Asian friend I
think it's disproportionately skewed
towards the east in terms of population
and when my business partner Dave is
about two beers deep if he's forgotten
to have one of his special pills he just
looks like he's been out in the Sun for
too long and he just instantly gets like
a like a flush flush face but you see
super funny in the middle of the night
out the interesting thing about alcohol
here is that here in the northern
northern part of the globe you know
Finland Russia people drink a lot you
know and we are we are actually quite
tolerant to alcohol so we don't get the
red flush reaction that easily
genetically and that might sound like a
good thing that you can deal with
alcohol more but the problem here is
addiction so if you're not getting the
beating of getting a red flashing
reaction you risk yourself you know
getting addicted more easily there's no
early warning system right yes there is
no punishment but there is all the
reward so you get basically there the
release of dopamine and it makes you
feel good and enjoy yourself and in
terms of any addiction what is key is
repetition and the sequence and the the
time or
between the moments when you release a
certain pathway or connect certain
neurons in your brain so becoming an
alcoholic is not really about the amount
how much you drink it is about the
frequency so if you enjoy alcohol
because you're not getting this red
flash reaction you start drinking wine
at every dinner
suddenly you drink bottles of wine
that's the problem the frequency of use
is the issue here and over time that's
that's that's also what makes you an
alcoholic and you start to enjoy it it
wires your brain for that activity now
if you get the punishment every time you
drink you're more likely to steer away
from drinking and if you do you could
just you're super careful and and I
think it's a blessing to get that
reaction yeah now you can hack that so
in biocking circles you can use things
like liposomal glutathione you can use
things like n-acetylcysteine which is a
building block for glutathione the
breaks down austell the height which is
want to metabolize of alcohol now it
sounds great is this a pre or post
that's a that's the it's it's effective
when you do it pre or a while drinking
so it doesn't help that much once the
damage is done but that's part of the
reason why you can drink more if you eat
simultaneously because from food you get
from amino acids you get sisty and get
some building blocks some amino acids
that build up more glutathione so you
can break down alcohol it also slows
slows down the absorption obviously now
the the problem here is that if you
start supplementing on alcohol use which
is kind of a bio hack so you really risk
of getting hangover you know what you
can drink you can drink more you're more
likely to get addicted also III I spoke
to a researcher on this and he said that
you increase your risk for becoming
alcoholic tree fault by doing this by
hacks so that's terrifying man like it's
it's what you said before about the
nootropics and the use of smart drugs
you're layering on top of an
ineffective system more speed and for
people who listened to the episode we
did about mental models you'll remember
speed of a direction and a lot of the
time you can make yourself got much
faster in the wrong direction and this
is exactly what we're talking about a
lot of people ask like I recently did a
story about I mentioned the tropics and
had my inbox got flooded with all so
what what you recommend what do you use
and I'm like so many people say that
they have a time management problem when
what they have is an attention
management problem if you don't
understand how to do deep work or you
don't have the beginning of the
understanding of a Pomodoro Technique or
whatever your particular focused work
strategy of choice is but if you don't
have any like hammering shitloads of
nootropics and caffeine into yourself
you're layering extra speed on top of an
incredibly ineffective system you got it
I mean as a philosopher you might say
that you know there is time you know
infinite amount you know it comes and
goes what do you have a limited amount
is your attention so if you if you do a
bunch of nootropics and all that like
and you think you have a time management
problem you really have an attention
management problem that's for sure and
sometimes taking these substances that
might make you hyperactive might make
you a little bit too stimulated little
bit too much dopamine they might make
you more easily distractible actually so
it's a sweet spot I know this for myself
actually I thing is not a nice thing to
do if I want to write it's good if I
want to go for a run or you know talk to
you that's where it works for me because
it helps me to rapidly fire and you know
make connections but if I want to do
deep work or creative work I need to
slow down the system really like for me
things like things like the onion work
pretty well
things like lemon balm might be good
maybe a cup of tea so less stimulatory
things are good in that state for me or
just like yeah a degree for me for me as
well what I'm doing creative work when
I'm podcasting you know
a little bit more kind of speedy kind of
helps like so caffeine or whatever would
would be good but to me when I'm doing
creative work if I have too much I'm
overshooting by anxious anxious yeah I
can't I can't allow everything to slow
down and to really focus on what matters
so l-theanine is one of the things
you've touched on that so yeah going
going back to one of the things I
mentioned before if you were to take a
broad cross-section of people and say I
mean would you recommend to most people
a sauna I'm gonna guess so based on
everything that I've seen it suggests
that heat and cold therapy is robustly
pretty good are there any other
techniques that you think that are
fairly robust and that most people
should consider adding into a routine if
they're they're new to biohacking they
haven't yet got the book and they don't
know where they're where to start
there's some things the evening will
just give them some good benefits to
begin with
I mean I'm beating the horse to death
here but light is obviously a big thing
so there's a lot of research that has
come out in the last couple of years on
chronobiology
so basically the biology of your
biological clocks and light is a big
influencer on that diet is another one
by the way so when you drink coffee that
actually pushes your particle clock
forward by four hours easily absolutely
that's really worrying yeah I mean if
you are traveling and you try to adjust
the time zone that might be good things
like fasting will be good because
biologically we are wired to move the
clock forward until we get food so I
would always so I think about morning as
one of the resets for the day so
starting a day with coffee but not the
first thing when you wake up because
that's when you have high cortisol when
you your adrenal glands are just waking
up pushing more caffeine into the system
to activate your adrenal glands is is is
like putting more gas on the pedal
that's already pushed way down so I
would wait for the cortisol to drop so
much that typically so that that's
probably
around a couple of hours from wake up so
I would make the coffee yes I would put
it in a tare mo I would take it to the
to work and I would drink it slowly and
you're an advocate of the 11 in salt
water on the morning right when it comes
to hydration I would go for electrolytes
for sure I mean you lose a lot of water
when you sleep so hydration is key and
you need electrolytes for absorbing the
water so the more fluids you have in
your body the better your system also
work your joints your disks a lot of
back pains can actually be a result of
hydration so there's not just you know
enough fluids in your system to moisten
up you know things like the disks in
your body hydrated discs is what is what
it's referred to right it's one of the
technical tell strip that's right so
hydration is key but when it comes to
like hacking your morning water what I
like to do is if I would if I now had
everything in my disposal what kind of
morning water would I do I would
actually use not filtered water or
something fancy like that I would use
either spring water or birch sap birch
sap directly from a tree that's awesome
it's already full of all the
electrolytes the natural form I would
ferment it so I would have fermented
birch sap so I get also the probiotics
if I don't have those I'm gonna make
some probiotics in there perhaps what I
would also throw in in terms of our
people put things like lemon for some
vitamin C I might use things like spruce
sprout powder or Amla extract Amla extra
and spruce brows are one of the greatest
sources of vitamin C or I might also use
sea buckthorn Chuy's just you know dose
a little bit of that in there I might
throw some things to help with Auntie
basically anti-inflammatory compounds I
might throw something like an extract of
ginger or
or turmeric in there also also beans of
pinch of salt is a pretty good idea so
there you have it you know you have
already a more like an optimized version
so your question like what would most
people benefit from I give you a I don't
keep I'm gonna give you a way of looking
at things so when you look at your day
look at the things that you do
repeatedly you see it in a chair you
sleep in a bed you drink a cup of coffee
or tea or whatever you do you know look
at the things that you do repeatedly
over and over again and those are the
areas if you optimize those you get
cumulatively the highest benefits from
so there is not a single thing but I
would look at your patterns of behavior
I would map them out and think about
like how can I do this better and don't
compromise some things like your the
quality of coffee or tea or your chair
or bed because those are the things you
spend most time with a lot of people
they buy things that they think they
need like a fancy car or I don't know a
new shirt and they don't invest in small
things like much better like a
ergonomics so that's what I would go for
and if you do a lot of seating work
getting some way to get more mobility in
your day maybe a standing desk the point
is not to stand all day long but it's
really to altered your physical position
that's kind of the key for activating
your lymphatic system so I would pay
attention to stimulating your lymphatic
flow because the the lymphatic system
doesn't have a pump like the heart does
for the cardiovascular system it
requires movement and gravity for for
the fluids to move in and out from from
from yourselves
so the speaking is speaking as someone
who considers himself active I train
between one and two hours a day seven
days a week but the periods when I'm not
active or incredibly sedentary and this
the
is a missed step a bias that I've not
been conscious of until fairly recently
I thought right well I'm cracking out in
an hour and a half I'm cracking out a
thousand or a 1,500 calorie workout like
I don't need to worry myself with
staying mobile through the rest of the
day
whereas recently the guys from fully
they make the capisco chair and they
make the job it's desk that is what I'm
sat on now so this stool which is just
behind me and this particular desk which
allows me to stand like this is this is
now I'm working with an adjustable desk
and for the listeners at home they'll
know that I have l5 and s1 for me at two
bulging disks I have that habit what's
referred to as a smalls node and you
think well I have fairly strong
extensors I have all of the rest of the
things but it's not it seems it's not
sufficient to just look after your
health or your fitness during fitness
time staying moving throughout the day
an episode I did with dr. you and Lawson
who is the author of the healthy writer
came up with something called the
20-20-20 rule which I thought was great
and it ties in with Pomodoro's and said
every 20 minutes for 20 seconds stand up
walk around and look at something which
is more than 20 feet away and he talks
about resetting the ocular muscles in
the eye to try and there's been some
moderately strong research to show that
it will stop with tension headaches and
the straining of the eyes being in a
scream which is a particular distance
away so that's that's something to take
that so we're looking at the areas of
our life that we're doing a lot of if
you're a driver look at your seating
position in a car if you're an office
worker look at your desk position look
at where your keyboard is if you're
everyone's gonna say if you sleep
everyone's things when you sleep
consider your sleeping position your
pillow the surface you are sleeping on
what some of you other areas that people
may have overlooked yeah well I started
just reflecting on what you said and to
me it seems like you know if you take
exercise even
people have recovery days and you know
that's when they don't do anything and
there is a bunch of research that
actually shows that an active recovery
day is probably actually better to have
a little bit of movement in the day and
maybe go for a walk so one of the key
things for a long life definitely once
you get older once you know that you are
young you're gonna do you know all kinds
of heavy exercise and stuff like this
but the older you get it's it's more and
more important to get your
proprioceptors right and it's
proprioceptive proprioceptors I think
yeah yeah that's kind of key so moving
an uneven terrain you know go don't just
go for a run on a treadmill or around a
field but God just go to the you know
down away from a beaten path and run in
nature and get some natural movement I
think that's key really for a brain
function and for learning and it I'll
show you I'll show you what I've
literally I've literally just bought
weather sure that's a great chair you
have there
this is slackline which as my yes some a
physical physical challenge yeah exactly
so that's gonna be my that's gonna be my
thing hopefully I'll get to get that set
up nearby I work from home a fair bit
get that set up at home and then yeah
when I tweet Bethy on grass I know
grounding another thing and stuff
there's a little bit of research behind
it I have started my first company when
I was 16 on 37 mile and when I was
younger you know 18 or something like
this my friends would go for a smoke and
for a cigarette and I didn't smoke so I
had to come up with something to do and
one thing that I came up with was
juggling so I started juggling I started
doing all these juggling acts and that
was what my way of getting a little bit
movement in my day and there's a bunch
of research that also shows that
if used if you train yourself in
anything that requires coordination of
micro movements like you know what you
just showed me that zip line or maybe
even playing something like a violin
juggling all those things dance or key
for increasing the connections in corpus
callosum which is the part of the brain
that connects the left and right
hemispheres there is this idea that
you're either left or right brained like
the geological or create it but this is
bollocks it's not based on any real
science it's some hippies came up with
that distinction in the 70s and it it's
stuck
I mean it came from brain imaging that
they noticed and and research on the
brain definitely other areas of the
brain that are you know more really
loaded activities but when you do
creative work you're actually using you
know both left and right hemisphere when
you're doing a logical mathematical
equations you're using both left and
right hemisphere and if you're gonna be
Einstein or not it's actually they
increase the number of connections you
have in your corpus callosum between the
rest and the light left and the right
hemisphere so the better the
coordination between both both sides of
the size of the brain the better you are
on both of those activities both
creative work and logical thinking so
and the best way to train that is
physical movement especially anything
that requires concentration and
coordination quite fine - ala t
technical sort of things like a violin
or a slacklining have you still got the
skill so you still got the juggling
skills if someone throws the set of
balls that you have you still got it
absolutely yeah I also got into contact
juggling and I also do some sticks and I
really love like you know to play with
some martial arts equipment if I get the
opportunity so I think it's a fun part
to play
you know also that's that's that's a
really cool point a lot of people forget
that these things that we're talking
about aren't just necessarily tools for
a more productive longer better life
that
the you can find I I suck at slackline
like I suck so bad well i'm i actually i
do enjoy the process of it i like being
out i've attached to two trees bare feet
on grass fresher half an hour and you
know it's it's fun like that's it is the
process of doing it isn't just like we
said at the very beginning it's not that
utilitarian tool for tools sake
it can actually be something that you
enjoy absolutely grazing the groove is
one of the kind of key terms that have
been thrown around in exercise circles
the basic ideas that you play all day
long it just don't go for a gym workout
you do pushups occasionally do pull-ups
maybe you do you know you you you do
some parkour was once you're outside in
a series so you're trying to find some
ways to use your body at its forced form
i have to testify that you know i don't
do that all the time i'm still learning
you know i try to get more and more
playful and more exercise to my day and
I'm getting there you know I just got
myself an extra bar and I do my what
it's a resistance training system
developed by a doctor I try to remember
his name now but anyway so he X X 3 X 3
bar yes so basically what happens is
when you do something like deadlift yeah
the highest resistance is when you're
just lifting it off the ground and the
lowest resistance is is in the uppermost
position now the resistance bands are
reversing that so you have the highest
resistance on the upper position on the
lowest when you're down and it actually
pushes your training beyond what is
possible which is lifting heavy stuff
and I really like the device and it's
it's easy to carry around and it's it's
unforgiving I mean I call it a business
man's workout because you can do it you
know with your suit on hotel room yeah
hotel room 15 minutes and your company
wasted out of breath and you don't even
get too sweaty doing it so you can go
for a meeting right after a red-faced
that's really interesting um so before
we go some of the things we've touched
on today that I know the listeners might
be interested in you mentioned about the
biomarkers for lipids and glucose and
stuff like that
I was flown out to Boston as the
listeners will know by the guys from
inside tracker who do some biomarkers
they do a service in the UK and in
Europe although I'm aware that is a
slightly reduced version of their main
one which is all 14 biomarkers and you
also mentioned about genetic testing
have you got any companies that you
recommend for the biomarkers for
Dianetics the inside tracker is great if
you want to check biomarkers against
your diet they have a do it yourself so
it's also where you go to your local lab
yeah you get the numbers and you then
manually enter them on inside tracker
and you get your analysis another great
company in US side is called wellness FX
I think they were sold to Thorne FX a
supplement company I think but anyway so
they they did previous tensive panels
and on Europe side I mean there is there
is genetic company something you can do
like 23andme test and then upload the
data to companies like DNA fit and
Prometheus and there is also Lib wellö
and a bunch of other services there is
dr. around Patrick's genetic analysis
for nutrition and nutrigenomics that's
great
or you can go for a full genome test
with companies like chronemics which
also provides an epigenetic test or
Dante labs is another one that comes of
cost of that I mean these are i probably
cheapest you get them is like a hundred
fifty bucks and up to a thousand yeah
the real every full about a yeah but I
wouldn't definitely go for a genetic
test us the first thing I would get my
basic biomarkers in place I actually
sold my own problem here trying to get
you know this lab test in Finland we
founded a company I helped to found a
company called health DX that does
biomarker analysis so we do very
extensive full blood tests so like over
100 biomarkers and we have another
package that's for the basic metabolics
but we have another package which is
nutrition where we look at
micronutrients vitamins minerals and we
also looked at from full-blood and so
you get a long-term understanding of
many many things and we are working with
the only mineral laboratory in Finland
to do that and we are not just providing
you the numbers but we also provide you
the deeper analysis and feedback on
those so actually our biomarker analysis
comes with a an online course that helps
you to dive in a customized manner to
your own blood work and the amount of
material that you can learn from there
about your biomarker results is about
the same size as the Barkers hand we are
actually putting that as a book later
also so so the buyers handbook is is out
now you can find more information about
it from Barker from biohacking book comm
so barking book.com you can already
order the Barkers handbook it's not an
amazon yet we're working on it
it's a big book it's a big book to hit
by Amazon yeah it's a big one
it's also big for us too to get it there
especially on the US side we're working
on it and there is some there are some
books that are coming out later so we
are working on one book that is more
focused on your nervous system and
building resilience so that will be a
follow up to this book we were that be
kind of like on top of the immunity side
yeah that will combine basically
everything that goes into stress
management and building a better
resilience version resilient version of
yourself so that will go in more in a
more detailed manner into breathing
techniques
called heat exposure and but also
supplementation for our adrenal and HPA
axis that controls your stress reactions
also I mean if the listeners at home I'm
sure making a lot of notes and then
trying to catch up with a lot of what
we've gone through today my taking notes
from reading the biohackers handbook is
moving very slowly embarrassing them
reading the book very slowly cuz I'm
then having a distill down what it is
that I'm looking at but I have to say if
you thought that there was a wealth of
information in today's episodes that is
about as close to an encyclopedia as
you're going to get I think you've done
a fantastic job with it you get like a
PDF that's kinda like a partner of it as
well
and then is the there's a link to stuff
on the website which is all the
recommended products and resources and
stuff like that I haven't even started
on that yet like that still for me to
get stuck into yeah so in this book you
don't have any product or device or
service recommendation radicals those
will be basically outdated in a year so
we we took all those out from that book
so that book is mainly researched
strategies based on science over 1,500
references mainly meta-study is
published in a scope of years so this
material will last a long time and once
we get into the different practical
techniques and tools that's where we
have our extra materials pages which are
like online databases for everything
from for sleep optimation exercise
nutrition all that and we keep on
updating those lists as we go forward as
new stuff comes out when we started
writing this book five years ago so I
work with a medical doctor called also
VR way and a nutrition specialist called
the alcohol mentor when we started
people didn't do things like for the bio
modulation that much blue light blocking
was not yet there like glasses some of
those things were kind of already
emerging a little bit key
Oh genic diets were not really big
people were talking about more about
anti-inflammatory diets and and all that
so things have changed a lot while we
were writing this and we've been
updating the book while we wrote it for
five years and but I mean it's it's a
huge book a lot of research went into it
and for no reason I mean it's not a
surprise that when you put your heart
and mind into something like that you
know people people really give good
feedback so we help have already a
second 100 you know five star reviews
and raving reviews about the content
it's a coffee table book really I mean
you can't just read it digest it in one
go it's something you want to go back to
as often as as you have questions yeah I
think certainly one of the things you
touched on with your the potential for a
morning water right and that recipe for
a morning water is probably more lengthy
than most people's lunches and I think
that the overwhelm that comes with that
you are right you need to pick apart the
the elements that you need but you know
to have a heuristic for prioritizing
you've given it it's one of the things
that you do the most one of the things
the you know know like as the whoever is
listening what are the things that that
person does the most these are the areas
in which any small increases will
compound most effectively over time yes
so we research like what is the 20% out
of all the material out there that has
any likelihood of doing something and we
handed over to the readers now if you
did everything that we have for example
in the sleep optimization chapter you
would be preparing for sleep all day
long oh it's your task then to figure
out like out of that material what
resonates with you what works for you
what is the 20% of the recommendations
that you know you could fit into your
daily schedule and we guarantee that
most of those are research that
they will definitely statistically
perhaps improve your sleep but you can't
know really until you try yourself
so that's the value of patient zero you
know being n n is one being the one who
is being the guinea pig for all these
self experiments so when you read stuff
online or you hear experts you know do
you do your own research try those
things on yourself be it well informed
be guided by the best experts but in the
end you don't know until you try
yourself
see me it's been fantastic to speak to
you by hacking book calm and why can
everyon find you if they need to get you
online so I mean you can you should
definitely come to bio hacker summit so
biker summit takes place first and
second of November in Helsinki Finland
it's our five-year anniversary and and
there is a lot of people more
intelligent than me and by hacking or
coming along like we over half of our
half of the people coming along are from
other countries than the Nordic
countries and we get often over 30
different nationalities but if you want
to follow me online I mean just look for
biocking book on Instagram I also have
personal account ta r1 n a liked arena
my first name
Teemu arena tour inna if you thought in
actually means story so I'm story time
you are a storyteller indeed your
storyteller of making people's lives a
little bit less [ __ ] than they are
already
and in it making everyone a little bit
healthier manic see it's been it's been
awesome today
thank you so much for your time my
pleasure my pleasure have a healthy you
know rest of the day and the rest of
your life
[Music]
you